A long time ago,...
...before the Egyptians, the Cambodians or the Aztecs,...
...Antarctica had no ice.
People lived here.
Bouvetoya Island.
But it's not on the ice.
It's 600 meters under it.
Find somebody else.
Will we do better with you or without you?
My job is to keep you all safe...
...and you can help me.
Never go anywhere alone.
Be ready, bad things can happen on the ice.
I don't understand it.
There's nothing here.
No sign of another team.
When they gave their lives,...
...the hunt could start.
This is unusual.
I think something broke out of this body.
The thing on the roof was a Predator.
It was time,...
...time for them to go to the pyramid.
These were the Alien Queen's eggs...
...and the things inside them were new aliens.
There was no way out.